we have breaking news coming out of
Zurich FIFA president Sepp Blatter is
going to resign he is calling for a new
presidential election just days after
being elected to a new term just to
recap the news said bladder is speaking
in Zurich right now this is a FIFA
colleague said bladder was just onstage
saying that there needs to be a new
president he's going to call an
extraordinary Congress as soon as
possible he says the mandate was not
supported by everybody referring to
friday's vote he says FIFA needs
profound restructuring joining me now to
discuss is bloomberg's Brendan Greeley
also co-host of Bloomberg surveillance
Brendan for years corruption allegations
have dogged this man and he has been
defiant as the head of FIFA and suddenly
this change of heart do you have any
sense of why I I don't I'm as shocked as
you are I am looking at these headlines
one jumps out at me FIFA president
bladder says mandate not supported by
everyone so there's obviously there is a
political mandate and then there's just
route raw power so obviously he won the
politics of the vote where's power
contained within FIFA I would say two
things one is you had more people coming
out publicly saying he should not be
president than ever before nobody dared
to do that right and when people speak
out against you that's a sign of your
loss of power but I think when you get
there Michel Platini the head of the
European up with it yeah knowing
Nichelle Vanessa me of all personal me
of all people correcting your French um
but yeah no angel himself saying that
you know that they're not gonna stand
for that I think that when we're talking
about everyone what we mean is the
sponsors this is pure conjecture there's
been no public note of this but I can't
think of anyone wielding the power that
the sponsors do and stepping in and
saying okay you had a pretty good run
there this this is gonna have to change
going forward this is such a profound
change of tone from what he said
defiantly after his election it's my
Congress I'll take the last word I'm
going to take us forward on only friday
that i can only imagine that this is not
pressure coming from a wafer the
european leagues this is not coming from
the US prosecutors this is his sponsors
again pure conjecture but they are the
only organization or people that have
the power to sit down and make him
changes and certainly that was something
we did
saw the likes of visa McDonald's many of
the giant corporate sponsors and with
the conversation we were having was is
FIFA just too big to drop it doesn't
matter that it's corrupt fans are still
going to tune in oh yes and it doesn't
matter for the sponsors because they
it's such an attractive advertising
platform they wouldn't want to walk away
it is hard to put my finger on what's
exactly changed this time um I I am
guessing that what made this big enough
for him to actually change direction or
even resign is that this is an actual
legal proceedings right there have been
that that goes all the way to FIFA there
have been indictments and even
convictions of various people in the
associations around the world there have
been internal hearings that they've had
this is the first real legal proceeding
with any weight that goes all the way to
FIFA and I suspect that they know
internally again pure this is pure
conjecture we know that the person named
in the indictment was Jerome falka this
is his second in command and that we
have no idea how much farther all right